[Musique]
aujourd'hui le terrible les arts
s'ils se passait il ya bien longtemps en
amérique du sud avant que les espagnols
ne l'êtes envahi les incas régnait alors
sur un immense territoire qui recouvrait
toute la cordillère des andes jusqu'au
pacifique
ces sujets parlait le quechua et aymara
il vénérait le soleil et la lune comme
leur maître ils leur faisaient des
sacrifices
dans un petit village de la cordilière
eelv est une jeune fille du nom de ici
cha son père qui était un pauvre
cultivateurs l'avenir est il ne savait
que faire pour la contenter que tu es
jolie ici de chat il est il parfois
lorsqu'il rentrait de ses dure journée
de labeur et c'était vrai ici cha était
très belle et tous les garçons des
environs on était amoureux mais elle ne
leur prêter aucune attention
le jour où elle eu 18 ans elle de se
rendre chez le senior un cas de la
région comme toutes les jeunes filles de
son âge pour lui offrir ses services
pendant toute une année
hélas ma petite fille sanglote à la mer
en la serrant sur son coeur le temps va
me paraître bien long mais enfin nous
pouvons y échapper et dans son for
intérieur ici cha pensait vivement que
j'allais découvrir le monde
le monde ce fut la maison du cacique
avec ses dépendances
et si déjà comme les autres servante s'y
trouvent a confiné dans les cuisines
mais bientôt arrive à la fête du maïs il
devait y avoir un grand banquet présidée
par le seigneur au cours de ce repas un
groupe de jeunes filles viendrait danser
le pou li pou li le chaco et la danse
des héros à sa grande joie ici cha fut
choisi pour en faire partie
la plus jolie des danseuses étaient sans
conteste
et si jo
cacique ébloui ne pouvait en détacher
ses yeux qui est elle demanda-t-il à
l'un des serviteurs qui agite est
derrière lui un grand éventail de plumes
c'est une jeune fille qui travaille ici
pour l'année
le cassis qui demeura à pensif
elle est bien trop belle sont gentilles
pour demeurer une simple servante
elle est digne des plus grands honneurs
il en devint bientôt si amoureux qu'il
décida d'en faire sa femme il y eut des
fêtes splendide pour les noces auquel
fut invité toute la noblesse des
environs mais mais on oublia d'y convier
les parents disciples d'alors celle ci
fut couverte de bijoux et de parures
merveilleuse son mari lui interdisait le
moindre travail mollement étendu sur les
coussins tous le jours la jeune épouse
seul essai est vantée par les serviteurs
qui lui apportait boissons et sucreries
varié dans les couloirs et les cuisines
maugrey on voit là une pimbêche ça ne
fait pourtant pas bien longtemps qu'elle
n'était encore qu'une sable paysanne
elle se prend déjà pour une princesse
en effet la vanité et la coquetterie 10
in châ ne faisait que croître sa famille
elle l'avait complètement oublié
cependant les siens sans nouvelles
d'elle depuis plusieurs mois
commençaient à s'inquiéter
un soir son permis est un plus dès
demain j'irai moi me chercher notre
fille dit il à sa femme prépare - la
besace le lendemain à l'aube
il prit son bâton son punch au de laine
de lama est suivi le long de la montagne
le sentier escarpé qui devait le mener
au bourg de collias comme ils étaient
épuisés lorsqu'ils arrivent h et le
cacique ses pieds étaient en sang la
sueur coulait le long de son visage il
fut reçu par un serviteur glacial au
visage impénétrable
je suis le père d'une jeune fille nommée
ici de chat dit il d'une voix cassée par
la crête l'émotion et je vient la
chercher et site chat mâle du sien
l'homme décontenancé et c'est le nom de
la jeune fille que notre maître a épousé
deux mois dernier
voyons vous devez vous trompez insisté
le père je vous en prie je désire
l'avoir ici szczesny de ne rien
comprendre à ce que lui rapporta le
serviteur mais enfin elle accepta de
recevoir ce vieillard qui la réclamait
avec tant d'insistance elle jouait
négligemment avec les franges dorées de
sa tunique lorsqu il pénétra dans la
pièce ébloui par le luxe qui
l'entouraient elle contemple avec mépris
ce vieux paysan au visage buriné aux
pieds nus aux vêtements usés ici de
chars ma fille bien aimée s'écria-t-il
que je suis content de t'avoir retrouver
qui es-tu vieux pouilleux réplique à
t-elle durement je ne te connais pas
incrédules les yeux exorbités le
vieillard écoute à raisonner en lui les
paroles de sa fille il ne pouvait croire
attend d'orgueil et de méchanceté
pendant un moment il sembla que son
corps ça fait c'est que son visage se
plie c'est d'innombrables rizzo mer mais
bien vite il se redresse à ses yeux
lançaient des flammes de sa main droite
il agitait un bateau malheur à toi
mauvaise fille s'écria-t-il d'une voix
rauque du malheur à toi qui méprisent ta
famille prend bien garde
lorsqu à ton tour tu auras un enfant tu
ne trouveras pas assez de larmes pour
pleurer ton infortune sur cette
application
le vieillard s'en alla pour ne plus
revenir ici de chats semblent à d'abord
fâché de cet incident mais l'oubli a
bien vite car elle aide est insouciante
au bout de cinq années elle fut enceinte
a que je suis heureux ma chérie
s'exclame al caciques lorsqu'elle lui
annonce à la nouvelle il l'a comblé de
cadeaux lui offrit un bijoux dorés de
turquoise et organisa un grand festin
pour célébrer l'événement lorsque le
grand jour arrive à il y avait quatre
sages femmes choisies parmi les plus
expertes du pays au chevet du site chat
le cacique ne se tenait plus
d'impatience il répétait à qui voulait
l'entendre je suis sûr que c'est un
garçon le bébé qui n'a qui avait bien
dans les faits la tête d'un garçon avec
des yeux vers une peau toute rose de
petites mains bien formés mais oh
surprise
le reste de son corps était celui de
lézard aux écailles et verbales
environ grand communaux douanes les
sages-femmes retint un cri d'horreur la
jeune mère s'évanouit lorsqu'on lui me
sont lus et dans les bras quant aux
caciques il entra dans une violente
colère qu'on jette les sages-femmes à la
porte ce sont des incapables
logique il pendant trois jours il se
taira dans ses appartements
le bébé grandit c'est dans le berceau en
or massif où il reposait entouré de
draps de lin et des tofs somptueuse son
camp monstrueux n'était pas apparent car
il était l'ange et jusqu'au cou à la
manière des cas
[Musique]
mais voilà qu'un jour il fut en âge de
marcher ce fut un singulier spectacle le
voir ramper avec une longue queue
visqueux aux écailles verdâtre qui
s'agitaient dans tous les sens comme
celle d'un serpent pourtant on essayait
de donner une vie normale optical qu'un
cartel était le nom de l'enfant les arts
il était entouré de soins attentifs les
serviteurs devait l'ordre de se plier à
ses moindres désirs n'est pas s'il est
après tout se disait ici cha qui
s'habituent est à la monstruosité de son
fils gâtés comme il l'était par tout son
entourage privé de la compagnie des
enfants de son âge qu al khadra bien
vite un enfant terriblement capricieux
exigeant coléreux et puis il ne prenait
pas d'exercice il ne faisait pas grand
chose de toute la journée
alors il devint gras énorme
il était répugnant lorsqu'il eu 18 ans
il déclara un jour à ses parents qu'il
voulait se marier au moment où garçons
ce n'est pas possible s'exclama le
cacique et pourquoi donc pourquoi ne
pourrais-je pas vivre comme les autres
de toute façon vous qui êtes si riche
vous pouvez obtenir beaucoup de choses
c'est vrai dc cha son mari lorsqu'elle
se retrouve en tête à tête avec lui et
puis il n'est pas responsable de sa
disgrâce physique
nous devons faire pour lui le maximum le
lendemain le cacique covo qu'elle de ses
conseillers et le chargé de dénicher
dans les environs une jeune fille
fraîche et jolie qui pu convenir à son
fils dans les villages on a cueilli le
messager avec méfiance
paraît que ce garçon là à très mauvais
caractère lui en sûrs et certains
importants regardez comme son père a été
amoureux de la jeune ici de chaque homme
il l'a comblé de cadeaux observer les
autres on retrouvera malgré tout une
famille très pauvre qui se laissa
appâtés par les richesses promise
c'était des paysans misérables qui
n'avaient pas tous les jours de quoi
manger à leur faim après tout dire les
parents il n'est peut-être pas si
méchant que ça ce garçon les arts et
l'accord fut conclu le jour de la noce
arriva
c'était le cacique qui en tant que
senior de la région devaient unir les
jeunes mariés il avait envoyé aux futurs
beaux-parents des cadeaux magnifique sur
son ordre une confortable litière ornés
de plumes étaient allés chercher la
jeune fille au village
la fiancée était vêtu d'une tunique
orangée à fil d'or que lui avait tissé
sa mère à ses pieds elle portait des
sandales dorées
quant aux garçons les arts il s'était
assoupi sur un bon
en attendant l'arrivée de son épouse
deux serviteurs var le chercher le
soulevant chacun d'un côté ils adhèrent
à se tenir debout
il peut ainsi faire bonne figure pendant
la cérémonie
puis il y eut une grande fête à l'issue
de laquelle on organisa des danses et
des jeux tout le monde s'amuse a
beaucoup à quelle note joyeuse ce fut là
le soir tombe à le soleil disparu comme
une grosse orange bien mûrs comme le
voulait lusage le parrain et la marraine
du jeune couple accompagné alors protégé
jusqu'à la chambre prévue pour eux il
refermait la porte à double tour mire la
grosse clé dans leurs poches et
regagnèrent la salle de bal au matin le
parrain et la marraine qui était bien
fatigués d'avoir dansé toute la nuit et
tenait à peine sur les jambes 20 frapper
à la porte de la chambre
personne ne leur répondre alors le par
un tir à la clé de sa poche et ouvrit la
porte doucement au sic il ya t-il avec
horreur en découvrant le spectacle de la
chambre
la marraine avance à une tête prudente
et cru s'évanouir
le lézard dont la pensée est énorme tout
gonflé
reposait sur sur ses lèvres épaisses
standing dormait flow tel sourire béat
de l'homme retenu par terre éparpillés
dans toute la chambre il y avait des
eaux des fragments de chair
sanguinolente un morceau de crâne de
tibias que s'était il passé ont réveillé
le lézard qui d'abord grogna parce qu'on
l'a tiré de son sommeil mais qu'as tu
fait de la jeune fille
je les mange et les arts hutin hockey
n'a pas été sans mal je vous assure
enfin elle était bonne et ce tournant de
l'autre côté en grognant ils se rendent
hormis les sens les parents de la jeune
fille désespérée
au bout de quelques mois kalkar devint
agité nerveux et irascible les
serviteurs ne s'est approché de lui
craignant d'être dévoré je veux une
autre femme déclara-t-il un soir comment
après ce que tu as fait s'indigna le
cacique qui n'en est pas question voyons
quelqu'un a eu un violent accès de
colère son visage de vin rouge sort de
la bave sorti de sa bouche ou apparaît
ses dents pointues comme celle d'un
crocodile tremblant de frayant le
cacique se hâta d'approuver je ferais je
ferai le nécessaire monfils bégué y
at-il dès le lendemain il envoyait un
émissaire dans les villages des environs
et cette fois les choses étaient plus
difficiles mais on trouve a malgré tout
une famille extrêmement pauvres
désireuse de vendre sa fille et la même
horreur se reproduise
au grand désespoir des parents il est
encore deux ou trois mariages de la même
sorte car l'affreux lézard n'était
jamais satisfait enfin un jour une jeune
fille du village de lukala marca à
laquelle on proposait d'être la
cinquième épouse de calca aux arts refus
et tous mettent mois épousé ce monstre
jamais je ne veux pas être sa nouvelle
victime
le père un cultivateur misérable essaya
de gagner du temps prenant à part le
messager du cassis qui lui confia à voix
basse revenez dans une quinzaine de
jours on en reparlera or la jeune fille
qui se nommait schuhl cas restée sourde
aux prières de son père pourtant elle
avait bon coeur et se rendait bien
compte qu'il lui fallait venir en aide à
sa famille
mais de cette façon là c'était
abominable
elle alla trouver une sorcière
après avoir entendu le récit de foulques
à la sorcière resta silencieuse un long
moment ses yeux tristes et délavé
prirent à la lueur du feu une bizarre
teinte rouge
maintenant tu ne mourras pas littell
enfin d'une voix calme à condition que
tu suives bien mes conseils
[Musique]
lorsque tu entreras dans la chambre
nuptiale le lézard te demandera comme il
l'a fait pour les autres de te mettre au
lit la première du refusera et n'aura de
cesse qu'il ne se soit couché avant toi
puis il est un drap la lumière du
jettera l'or en direction du lit cette
poudre enfermé dans le flacon que voici
mais gardent de toi bien quoi qu'il
arrive de rallumer la torche tu t'en
repentir est la jeune fille retourne à
toute joyeuse chez ses parents j'accepte
la proposition du cacique déclara-t-elle
un peu étonné de cette soudaine docilité
ces parents-là remercièrent et
l'embrassait re avec effusion le jour de
la noce fut bientôt fixés les parents de
calca pâle et rongé d'inquiétude
accueillir leurs futures et nouvelles
belles filles avec beaucoup de
sollicitude
il eut comme la première fois une fête
magnifique
lorsque les deux époux furent seul dans
la chambre nuptiale
tout se passa au début comme l'avait dit
la sorcière le lézard dû accepter de se
mettre au lit le premier puis il est ni
la torche la jeune fille cru s'évanouir
dépôt vente mais d'un geste vif elle
projeta en direction du lit la poudre
que lui avait données la sorcière le
coeur serré elle entendit des bruits
bizarres qui provenait du des
frottements des craquements mais les
avais soupire son coeur se met à battre
un rythme affolés et si la sorcière
c'était propre et jeu se passe t'il eu
mon cher époux dit-elle d'une voix
faible
pour plus de réponses
folle de terreur choules catane alors
obscurité et découvrit la torche qu'elle
allume a tant bien que mal elle lape
rocha du lit ce qu'elle vit lac loi de
surprise au lieu du monstre au visage
cruelle qu'elle s'attendait à voir
il y avait là un beau jeune homme
inconnu
trop tard murmura-t-il d'une voix triste
tu a désobéi en allumant la torche
ge était délivré de mon enchantement et
tu aurais pu me sauver mais par ta faute
je dois désormais de dire adieu et
s'évanouit dans un nuage et disparus par
la fenêtre
dehors le vent faisait rage à travers la
montagne et le lendemain lorsqu'il
ouvrit la porte et qu'on va délivrer la
courageuse soul cas on ne trouva dans le
lit à côté d'elle que tu as des cayes
verte
[Musique]